Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 64.
Wann sind Sie genau gebaut?
Am 26. März 1961.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,83 m groß und 680 kg schwer.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Dr. Lindemann.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Neumann?
61.
Gut. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 4. Februar 1963.
63.
Gut. Herr Neumann, wie groß sind Sie?
1,79 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
88 kg.
Herr Neumann, was bierst du zu uns?
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Schneider?
Ich bin 74 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 10.10.1950.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schneider?
Ich bin 1,76 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zuzeit?
89 kg.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein, nicht. Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich auf irgendwas allergisch bin.
Super. Perfekt.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausärztin?
Das ist Frau Dr. Krüger.
Mit U-U-Maut, ja?
Ja, genau.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Weber?
Ich bin noch 64 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie geboren?
Am 16.04.1960.
Ich werde also in Kürze 65.
Herr Weber, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
92 kg.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich habe jahrelang als Kraftfahrer gearbeitet.
Aber in letzter Zeit fällt mir das zunehmend schwer.
Ich bin kurz vor der Rente.
Es wird ein bisschen anstrengend.
Kraftfahrer?
Ja, also LKW.
Wo wohnen Sie?
In Köln.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausärztin?
Dr. Schräder.
Danke. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 32 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
25.04.1992.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,63 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Ungefähr 65 kg.
Danke für die Information.
Herr Berger, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 49 Jahre alt.
Ich bin geboren am 4. November 1975.
1975.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,72 m groß.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
60 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12. April 1965.
Ich bin ein
65.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,84 m groß.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
93 kg.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarztin?
Das ist Frau Dr. Lang.
Lang.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Lindermann.
Herr Koil, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 57.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 16. Mai 1968.
68.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,82 m groß.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
89 kg.
Sie sind nicht so oft, aber genau.
Herr Bettge, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 46.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 18. April 1946.
60, oder?
46.
Ich bin 46 Jahre alt.
78.
Das ist normal.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,78 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 46.
Sie müssen sich jetzt vorstellen.
Ja, so 114, 115 kg wiegen ich.
115 kg ungefähr.
Ja, ungefähr.
15 kg, okay.
Herr Bettge, haben Sie schon gesagt
und Ihre rechte Beine
haben Sie ganz stark geschmessen.
Nein, nicht im Bein, im Fuß.
Rechte Fuß, okay.
Seit wann haben Sie denn?
Gestern Abend oder eigentlich in der Nacht schingen das an.
Ich bin aufgewacht und bin aufgeschreckt.
Wieso tut man so?
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege 93 kg.
Herr Hauskotter.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Okay, waren Sie genau geboren?
Am 14. Mai 1968.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege 95 kg.
Okay, vielen Dank für den Angaben, Herr Schmidt.
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Schregermann?
Ich bin 76 Jahre alt.
76 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 12. April 1948.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ja.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,76 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
80 kg.